le ministre de l'Intérieur Géral daranin
veut que les forces de l'ordre ai accès
aux conversations WhatsApp des Français
regardez et dites-mous si vous êtes
d'accord avec Géral daranin c'est parti
tu peux réagir aussi je pense que devant
la menace qui augmente c'est une
question que les démocraties doivent
poser au géants du numérique du coup moi
je veux dire au français qu'on est
capable d'aller sur telgram sur WhatsApp
et sur signal simplement comment on fait
on prend possession de notre téléphone
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé dans
cette affaire terrible d' race ce
monsieur ça faisait à peu près 3 mois
que nous l'écoutions téléphoniquement on
avait des dizaines d'heures en
conversation chechenen que la DGS a
traduit à l'heure près si nous avions un
moyen de porte dérobé comme vous dites
si nous étions capable de dire à
WhatsApp à signal à télégram donnez-nous
la conversation de cette personne parce
qu'elle est présente une menace nous
gagnerions
énormément alors g tu es pas d'accord
pourquoi mais il a raison je suis 100 %
d'accord avec lui mais le privé c'est le
privé on peut pas donner comme 100%
d'acc on peut pas donner des moyens
disproportionnés quand il y a des écout
t mais si toi si toi tu étais ministre
de l'intérieur mais ça serait une
catastrophe toi tu devrais être ministre
de l'extérieur non mais vraiment non
mais franchement c'est on te mettrait
toujours dehors et
voilà rien que la loi on dirait une loi
d'exception pour une période d'exception
so
arrê tu pour t'occuper de de déjà je
vais pas le voir samedi dimanche ça va
me faire du bien je peux venir voir si
vous voulez t'emmerde pas je peux plus
je peux plus te bler oui maintenant tout
le monde passe par WhatsApp et si ça
peut résoudre des en plus vite avec des
des enlèvements des
conneries attendre on va attendre dire
il fallait pas qu'on fasse on fait on va
dans les téléphones on nira pas dans ton
téléphone si tuas rien à te reprocher si
tu es mise en examen si tuas fait une
gros de conversation acatou on va manger
ce soir on s'en fout non mais s rien
qu'est-ce qu'on s'en fout de tes
conversations tu crois qu'il va aller
chercher tes conversations à toi
Gérardin mais g ver on va manger ce soir
mais ferme ta
gueuleou je te laisse une note vocale tu
veux aller faire du shopping demain
qu'est-ce qu'il s'en fout Géral
darin non mais en fait je pense que
aujourd'hui nos démocraties elles sont
un peu faibles et elles sont naïves en
fait c'est un test géant c'est un test
grandeur nature et en fait il faut il
faut tout nous reparamétrer je pense
qu'il y a ouais aussi et je pense qu'en
fait il faut il faut tout reprendre à
zéro et je ne vois pas où est le
problème toi tu as une sorte de folie du
truc non mais tu as la folie c'est la
dictature que vous nous
pr moi je rêve de vivre en dictature
alors moi je rêve je rêve de vivre pas
dans le même pays que
toi
àentell desang
pourremocich tu veux défonc
m à partir de lundi je va faire une
nouvelle séquence qui veut
défoncer c'est scandaleux Gill de ne pas
vouloir donner tous les moyens à la
police pour arrêter tu avant qu'il passe
à
l'AM télé les arrê av sil te PLA tu as
vu ce qui se passe en ce moment là la
petite là toutes les petites les enfants
qui sont mais camér de surveillance
aussi par est contre les caméras de
surveillance auss ça vous pourrez pas
l'arrêter c'est pas de ça dont il s'agit
c'est de généraliser l'accès à la vie
privée de tous les Français tout mais tu
crois vra qu'ils ont que ça à fout ils
vont regarder les conversations de
Jean-Michel mer avec la meuf qui a chez
moi dans le public espèce
de espèce de que tu es ils vont ils vont
regarder des gens qui sont dangereux et
et au moins dans des enquêtes où il y a
des disparitions et cetera c'est très
importantizar il vouit pas que les
policiers soient armés hier pareil pas
que les policiers so arm veut pas les
caméras de surveillance qu'est-ce que tu
vas tu vas attraper qui toi par des
mouches vous Déat tu vas attraper qui
par des mouches il y a déjà suffisamment
de de règles qui
permettent tu vois bien moi je soutiens
totalement Gill ce soir oh
merde tu que je dis pour la première
fois tu t'exprimeras pas sur un
sujet moi j'aimerais de Moon moi en fait
je pense que effectivement c'est bien de
pouvoir regarder ce qui se passe sur
WhatsApp parce que ça peut permettre de
faire avancer des enquêtes plus
rapidement et de limiter peut-être
certaines choses mais par contre il faut
pas se leurer il y a d'autres
applications qui vont être mises en
place du coup pour si WhatsApp est
autorisé du coup il y en aura d'autres
et ça c'est enfin c'est juste des
créations de nouvelles nouvelles
application on déchiffrera tout ce qu'
monsieur non mais moi j'ai j'ai vraiment
pas peur qu'on qu'on me prive de
quelques petites liberté qui en
soit sur tes conversations WhatsApp mais
oui tu serais tu serais très surpris sur
ton période àiconos frère là tu verraas
c'est chaud euh mais pour avoir plus de
sécurité à l'heure où des gens sont
enlevés des gens sont tués des femmes
sont violées moi j'ai besoin de me
sentir en sécurité en fait c'est des
choses les plus importantes pour moi
donc regardez mon WhatsApp regardez mes
mes photos Ren c'est sû que Gill Verz le
monde de G on est pas en sécurité on se
fait squatter façon toi tu t'en fous les
mec tuas pas besoin d'aller voir le
WhatsApp sont directement chez toi en
train de Ch dans ton salon non mais
c'est vrai qu'est-ce qu'on as mais c'est
vrai excuse-moi
ouiou c'est vrai que les téléphones ça
regorge ça peut regorger d'information
donc si ça reste en cas d'enquête je
vois pas le le problème quoi si reg
alors j'hésite à faire parler les de
noms là pour avoir des vrais arguments
parce que Gill il a pas donné vraiment
d'arguments avoir des vra alors on va on
aura ma setong après pour l'instant on
va parler à
Delphine c'est le Colma effectivement
pour les personnes radicalisées pour les
tueurs pour les pédocriminels et tout ça
d'accord croez vraiment qu' va regarder
votre conversation dis-moi tu vas à la
fête de la choucrout samedi c'est qu'il
y a des choses très intéressantes dans
mes conversations bah écoutez non mais
il ira pas Gard Darmanin mais en tout
cas en tout cas ce que je voulais dire
le problème c'est qu'après on risque
d'All en fait on risque d'aller pardon
on risque d'aller dans une dérive avec
un état tout puissant et au bout d'un
moment quand sur WhatsApp quand on aura
la 20e vague il y aura marqué dans nos
conversations WhatsApp covid vaccin ou
quoi que ce soit et ben vous serez pas
tous très contents parce que au final
bah si c'est comme ça que les gens il
pouront si regarder ça c'est pour le
terrorisme et pour les
pédoc pour le retour du covid voilà on
l' oublié mais il va revenir et
effectivement suivi et tracé AC not
WhatsApp par rapport à no vacination
tous bien content pas marqué quand il y
a beaucoup d'actu il y a pas de covidou
voilà Puna de litas de lit les punaises
de lit tuas plus de punaise de lit il y
a plus rien il y a plus de COV plus de
punaise de lit moi je dors à poil les
gars il y a de semaines j'étais comme ça
depuis qu'il a une autre actualité on
parle plus de je dors à poil oui je dors
à poil oui monsieur moi je pense que
l'État n'a pas à tout savoir il y a pas
de demimesure dans ces CASL WhatsApp
signale et
uté ça veutil tout de notre vie
privé a non non mais c'est le problème
c'est le secret des sources aussi je
veux dire le secret des sources ça veut
dire que tu vas vers un état qui est en
mesure de tout savoir y compris des
enquêtes qui sont menées contre des
personnalités du gouvernement moi je
suis contre voilà ce princip aujourd'hui
vous faites penser à mon prof de dessin
en 4e2 monsieur sans rigoler il avait
des comme ça je l'embrasse d'ailleurs
mais moi j'aimerais lui répondre ah il
est je sais pas on sait pas on peut pas
il y a pas moyen de savoir Facebook je
l'embrasse les gens ils veulent plus de
sécurité donc enfin c'est une façon de
Hugo Hugo enchanté tu vas bien merci
merci d'être là Raymon non moi je
voudrais répondre à Jacques c'est quand
même hallucinant les personnes comme toi
qui disent ouais mais l'éat va nous
traquer vous avez vous êtes fait traquer
mais si tu dire après ils vont tous
savoir sur nous les sources ma pour
aller manger un hamburger ou une côte de
B vous avez tous fait le pass covid on
savait où vous étiez on savait où vous
alliez partout ça vous a pas dérangé
d'être traqué pourqui il étiez pas mis
en examen là on part si vous êtes mis en
examen si un juge vous dit voilà je vais
aller voir dans tes conversations parce
que ce que tu as fait c'est
grave
truten pour aller au cinéma vous AZ donn
au cinéma là j'é au restaurant là
j'étais dans cette boîte de nuit vous
êtes fait fler tout le temps partout ça
suffit ils ont
pas et tu penses au journalistes qui
font des enquêtes tu penses à moi je
pense pas au journalistes je pense
d'abord à la police Mo
la pilier de la
démocratie pas le cul propre on sait
maintenant voilà d'abord à la police
qu'est-ce qu'il veut mais vous vous
rendez pas compte de ce que vous allez
autoriser on se rend compte que vous
nous saoulez d'accord mais allezy le
ministre il a parlé d'une porte dérobé
les mots ont un sens il dit on va aller
sur WhatsApp pour par une porte dérobé
s'introduire c'est ce qu' a dit dans les
conversations introduit-toi chez Fatou
aussi une porte dérobé bon déjà déjà
déjà quand on dit porte dérobé quand on
dit porte dérobé ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire c'est la porte ouverte mais
les mots sens tu travaillis chez la
paire toi c'est la porte ouverte à entré
partout chez tout le monde il y aura
plus de vie privée tu crois vraiment tu
crois vraiment qu'ils ont que ça à
écoutter Gill verd qui va dire
mais frère qu'est-ce qu'on s'en fout de
ce que tu penses il le sait tous les
jours il sait que tu dis des conneries
non mais c'est pas moi le problème c'est
tout le
mondeèmeé qui partout chez tout le monde
dans la tête de rendez paste vous ne
vous rendez pas
comp on se rend compte d'un truc c'est
qu'en ce moment il se passe des trucs de
fou donc c'est sécurité maximale donc je
te le dis donc ce que tu dis tu dis
encore d'énormes conneries et si on
t'écoutait la France c'est pas qu'elle
irait dans le mur mais toi c'est c'est
dramatique écoute-moi bien tu n'as que
des idées rétrogrades et tu n'as que des
idées des années
6080 tu es très sécuritaire on v
meilleur van de l'émission C'est on
arrête là merci G est très sécuritaire
non mais si g non mais g est très
sécuritaire on aura pas mieux ce soir
bah les mecs c'est rideau si Gil est
sécuritaire alors rayon qu- non mais
c'est surtout part du principe que s'il
te dit qu'ils veulent casser le
chiffrement c'est qu'ils savent déjà le
faire donc c'est ça se trouve ils le
font
déjàèmeit faire c'est un problème ils
l'ont déjà demandé ils l'ont déjà
demandé au grand au grand américains à
Google et compagnie ils savent pas le
faire c'est impossible aucun pays fait
mais est sécurit même aux ÉtatsUnis ils
arrivent pas à le craquer vous vous
souvenez de la saillante qui s'en était
pris à des enfants dans un J il avait
récupéré céit un Syrien ils ont mis une
semaine à essayer de déterminer qui
c'était parce qu'ils arrivaient pas à
craquer le code le code de sécurité du
téléphone il y a un problème quand Mme
la française l'autorise pas et on a
perdu mais des jours et des jour pourir
qui
é dis qu' un problème de téléphone génal
il y a un problème de
téléphone ils on perdu une semain demain
si demain ils réussissent à trouver un
moyen de craquer des codes mais en ant
la la les conversations privées des gens
je serai d'accord mais si c'est tout
l'un ou tout l'autre je suis pas
d'accord moi je vous dire il vaut
trouver un moyen de me faire craquer
c'est de me faire passer une semaine
avec Gill Verdez en
vacances on va voir on va voir ce qu'on
pense les téléspectateurs tiens ah ben
voilà oui 41 % non voilà ils sont pas
d'accord et ben moi je suis complètement
d'accord avec Gill
Verdez je vrais dire que Gilles Verdez
est un des mecs les plus sécuritaire que
je connaisse actuellement vraiment mais
à mon avis ce qui a fait basculer le
sondage
de cette manière c'est absolument les
arguments de Delphine c'est le sanitaire
le covid non certainement pas agile
c'est tout ce qu'elle a dit par rapport
à ça où les gens se sont senti traquer
Etas pas fait mou tu as pas fait mouche
une fois que j'ai raison ça vous ennuie
donc vous trouz tuas pas fait mouche
tuas pas fait mouche tu as pas fait
mouche tuas pas fait
mouche